hello everybody welcome and thank you
for being here my name is Suzanne
Goldberg and I am the executive vice
president for university life at
Columbia University and a professor at
the law school here events like this
tonight showing of Selma and the
discussion are really not possible
without an enormous number of people
helping to make it happen and I want to
give special thanks to the office of the
president of Columbia University for
their great work on this event including
Kerry Walker Veronica Lake brick Gordon
and Jill casimiro and also to Brent
Brenna st. George Jones of the miller
theatre as well as to public safety and
see uit and I also would like to
recognize the tremendous work of the
small but energetic staff of the office
of university life Radhika Patel
Jonathan Morales and Frank are Joe VA
this is the inaugural event of the
universe the office of university life's
community citizenship series and it is
an especially fitting an important one
the office of university life has a
broad mission it has a mission to both
think and act broadly and in depth about
university life across the university
schools centers Institute's and in ways
that encompass the University students
faculty staff and community the focus of
this of the attention of the office of
university life is also broad and deep
on issues within our surrounding world
from the global to the national to the
local and the state and to the issues
within our own community the film Selma
dovetails with this broad and deep focus
it calls our attention to a time and a
place and a set of events that while
distant in some respects is also
terribly close in others whether we
think about Ferguson about Staten Island
and North Charleston or the supreme
court's striking down of critical parts
of the Voting Rights Act in 2013 and the
voter ID the voter ID laws in place
around the country or when we think
about the persistent barriers to
equality and the threats of violence in
so many domains in which we live and the
film
the story it tells asks asks and
encourages each of us to think and act
and do what we can in whatever ways we
can to secure and expand justice broadly
understood in all of our communities
both small and large tonight as members
of the Columbia community we do this in
three ways first we have a broad array
of Columbia's institutes and centers
that focus on race ethnicity disparities
and justice who have joined as
co-sponsors of this event I encourage
you to follow up with the ones that
interest you to sign up for their
mailing lists and to get involved second
we have an extraordinary group of
colleagues from around the university
including June cross from the journalism
school Jamal Joseph from the School of
the Arts Frances new grown montanaro
from the Department of English and
comparative literature and the Center
for the Study of an ethnicity and race
and patricia williams from the loss of
Columbia Law School and Samuel Roberts
will introduce in a moment this group
will share their insights their
questions their comments about the film
and its implications for all of us in
the discussion that will follow the
screening and third we invite you right
after the screening to share your
questions and ideas and comments via
twitter the hashtag is or I guess the
hashtag is see you Selma talk I'm not
much of a Twitter person but you can
find it there so that we can address
your thoughts both in the conversation
tonight and then in conversations
afterwards just a reminder not to do the
tweeting during the screening because
nobody wants to see the glow of your
phone during an intense movie like the
one we're about to watch together now it
is my pleasure to introduce professor
Samuel Roberts an associate professor in
the history department and at the
mailman School of Public Health and
director for the Institute of the
institute for research in
african-american studies professor
Roberts
good evening yeah there we go thank you
very much I am just here to briefly say
welcome and thank you to all of you for
registering and coming out this evening
I think this film if you haven't seen it
before if you have like myself you're
here to see it again it's something that
is still thought provoking the second
and third time that you may see it if
you haven't seen it you're in for
something which will leave you talking
about it probably for the rest of the
year and well and beyond it's very
fortuitous or shall we say appropriate
that the film that we were singing in
2015 50 years after the original Voting
Rights Act it is also appropriate and a
bit unfortunate that as Suzanne
mentioned these of the rights that we
enjoy as a result of that act are very
much under threat and it seems that
particularly with the the mind of the
Supreme Court even against how Congress
may vote that this at the the VRA could
be in jeopardy of being eroded in very
drastic ways I think it's important that
we talk about what this film represents
for us in terms of public memory and how
we think about history itself and what
we use history itself to move forward
and in what ways what strategies do we
employ at the Institute for Research and
african-american studies that's
something that we do every day of the
week we are in our in our very fiber of
our being so to speak in our DNA as very
dramatic language I know but it's a film
but what we do every day is public
engagement and thinking about the issues
that are at hand bday historical or
contemporary we will have a wonderful
discussion as Suzanne mentioned we have
some of some very good friends and
colleagues of ours here who have decided
to join us on this beautiful warm with
April evening after the film it should
be great and I also encourage all of you
to think about your questions during the
film for we will have a Q&A where we can
to all of us talk in conversation so
let's think about public memory let's
think about what are our not just our
rights what our duties as citizens in
terms of protecting
rights that were so hard earned 50 years
ago and let's think about we should
think on a national in a global level
but also thinking about this this this
smaller community that we call Columbia
University thank you so much for coming
I'm really looking forward to it and
enjoy the show as we're all taking our
seats tonight I just want to have a
moment of appreciation on behalf of
really all of us here for Anna Duvernay
for making such a moving and spectacular
thought provoking inspiring film and our
gratitude to her in the film and and and
the film producers for allowing us to
show it tonight so I'd like to welcome
you all to the conversation portion of
our evening both to those in the
audience at the miller theatre and to
those who are with us by live stream i'm
suzanne goldberg I'm executive vice
president of Columbia University and a
member of the faculty of the law school
here a film like Selma calls for
conversation immediately as we're about
to have and for long into the future
it's our time tonight is limited i
invite you to think of this part of the
evening and our conversation as a as a
time for sharing sparks of ideas
questions thoughts short comments to be
pondered now and to be returned to again
tomorrow and beyond just a few weeks ago
President Obama stood on the pettus
bridge and said if we want to honor the
courage of those who marched that day
then all of us are called upon to
possess their moral imagination all of
us will need to feel as they did the
fierce urgency of now he added that all
of us need to recognize that that sheet
as they did that that change depends on
our actions on our attitudes on the
things we teach our children and in the
context of a discussion at columbia i
would say on the things we teach our
students and all the things that we
teach each other with these words in
mind it's now my pleasure to introduce
our conversation partners I'll just do
this very briefly which is very very
difficult given who's here
and I want to ask you to google them all
after the evening to us so you can see
the full extent of the extraordinary
contributions everyone here has made
June cross to my left is a professor at
Columbia Journalism school and an
award-winning producer and writer with
over 30 years of television news and
documentary experience and I'll just say
I had to pick sort of one or two of
everybody's great work so it's it's a
very short selective version but among
professor crosses many well-known works
is her Emmy award-winning
autobiographical film secret daughter
and the book secret daughter a
mixed-race daughter and the mother who
gave her away Jamal Joseph next to
Professor cross is a professor of
professional practice at the Columbia
School of the Arts he is a writer
producer director poet and activist and
an Academy Award nominee in the original
song category and the acclaimed author
of the memoir and soon-to-be screenplay
Panther baby a life of rebellion and
reinvention about his life including his
experience as they as a member and the
youngest spokesperson of the Black
Panther Party next we have Pat Williams
butchered professor patricia williams
who is the james door professor of law
at columbia law school my colleague an
award-winning call scholar and a leading
critical race theory theorists among
professor Williams's works is the
well-known alchemy of race and writes
diary of a law professor you may also be
familiar with Professor Williams's
wonderful column diary of a Mad law
professor which comes out regularly in
the Nation magazine next to Professor
Williams is Professor Francis Negron
Montaner an associate professor of in
Colombia's Department of English and
comparative literature a leader of
Columbia Study Center for the Study of
ethnicity and race and of the media and
idea lab within the center she is also a
writer and a scholar with many
award-winning works to her credit
including Recondo el charco portrait of
a Puerto Rican which is the first Puerto
Rican film to examine issues of race
gender and homophobia in the context of
migration Samuel Roberts who I
introduced earlier and who's my partner
in facilitating the conversation tonight
is associate professor of history at
Columbia
associate professor of socio medical
sciences at the mailman school of public
health as well as director of the
institute for research in
african-american studies here among his
works is the book infectious fear
politics disease and the health effects
of segregation which explores the
political economy of health urban
geography and race in the late
nineteenth and mid twentieth centuries
now I'll turn it over to Professor
Roberts with a reminder to all of you to
add your questions to the mix via the
hashtag see you Selma talk and at some
point in the evening Radhika Patel the
chief of staff for the office of
university life will be bringing them to
our attention so we can engage with them
as well Sam thank you so much thank
everyone here yeah I also want to thank
office of programs and events again for
doing this this is a wonderful
opportunity to discuss an important film
and with such wonderful colleagues as
well I've been looking forward to this
for quite some time into the discussion
afterwards I thought it might be a good
idea to open up maybe with some
reactions we have amongst our panelists
filmmakers we have scholars activists
and I think from those various points of
view I'd be curious to hear your
reactions to the film and then also
maybe perhaps a bit of discussion about
what the public reaction has been I
imagine that many or all of you have
been watching the debates surrounding
the film about its veracity and etc it's
of the tone that it strikes shall we say
i think a number of people have just
taken issue with the tone even don't
know exactly how that works we can
discuss that but maybe we could open up
with some initial reactions and from
anybody threats for instance um I think
one of the things that strikes me about
the film is how self aware of an
intervention it is in the shaping of
public memory there are multiple
references in the film to the power of
media to hat as a shaper as a force in
the way we think about the past and the
way we relate to the present and I think
there's three kind of distinct ways that
the film attempts to produce an
alternative imagining to other existing
mortgage a hegemonic ones one isn't the
way that it relates elements that
otherwise would be absent from the
narrative so for instance the inclusion
of what we can call many instances of
the private transcript like James God
puts it in other words conversations
interactions that we would have the
probably no access to what happened even
in a recorded manner let alone by the
you know complexities of memory so in
providing us and imagine a proposition
or what that private transcript could
have been really you know situations to
think about relationships between events
between people between circumstances
that we might not otherwise be able to
imagine arts asked questions about I
think one of the things that might have
been disturbing to some viewers that
have expressed for instance you know
outraged at the way that LBJ has been
represented has to do with what we could
call a disruption in the relationships
on the palette of effect in the film for
instance in many many scenes in the film
you have that anesthetic of ugliness to
represent races the racist response and
in Hollywood film traditionally you know
whiteness is associated with good with
pure with you no heroics and in this
film there's a real a disruption of that
economy of effect and it's repeated
throughout as an aesthetic it's not only
a political in this in the big sense of
representing big political events but
also it's an aesthetic a formal
intervention in the ways that we narrate
and we tell stories and I guess I have
some ways that I think the film does not
entirely succeed in some of what it
proposes to do and I also have some
thoughts about continuities and
discontinuities that the film
proposes from a political but question
is that it raises from a political point
of view but I probably leave that for
later all right juna you had some
thoughts that you shared with us over
the past day or so concerning your
reactions I think this might be a good
time if I could um this is the second
time I've seen it and it was much more
emotional for me this time I don't I
didn't cry 5 times the first time I saw
it and I'm not quite sure why it was so
emotional for me but I also began to
think I was sort of picking back enough
what Francis said you know the power of
media Martin king is portrayed as being
very callous and had not really callus
about the actual lives of the people who
are putting their lives on the line but
the fact that he was willing to put
lives on the line in order to achieve
the greater goal and that it was really
a media entertainment show almost in a
way I was struck with on this viewing in
a way that I hadn't been the first time
because the first time I was watching it
was through the lens of having worked at
black side which did the original eyes
on the prize series and we did this
story as the documentary and this is the
movie not the documentary so you can get
very caught up when you're looking at
movies and thinking that well no LBJ
wasn't like that and Malcolm never
really met with Coretta and where
Stokely Carmichael he's not even
represented and what about all the
singing that they did when they went
back to the church that night after
bloody sunday and sort of rallied
themselves together and it really wasn't
about Martin it was about the people who
and snick and you know all those things
are in there but they're represent
different people represent different
things because it's a it's a it's a film
it's a movie not a documentary which I
often have to tell people that being
said i was also reminded of a film that
came out oh god 30 years ago called
mississippi Bernie that was pilloried
and ultimately sort of driven
underground because it portrayed in
Mississippi the FBI as being the good
guys and rescuing african-americans from
the clutches of the clan when in fact
the FBI was paying clan members to be
informants and they were perpetrating
violence
those who were fighting the good fight
in Mississippi and as I was sitting
there I said well okay if it matters
what role the FBI played in Mississippi
then it should also matter what role
Lyndon Johnson actually played and I
think it does matter and we can Josh I
feel at the end of the day there's an
emotional truth to the representation of
Lyndon Johnson in this film but in fact
there are things that are that he didn't
do he wasn't he wasn't as antagonistic
as he was at first portrayed it didn't
he was already sort of had the you
already had the foundation for the
Voting Rights Act sort of in hand when
the events of Selma unfolded so it's not
a nuanced portrayal of Lyndon but it's
an emotionally true portrayal of linden
and you know you just have to sort of go
back to your history books and go back
and watch the actual documentary from
eyes on the prize where we talked about
this this event in order to sort of
judge it against history into the degree
that it does that I think it's a
wonderful thing that it sends us back to
look at the actual record because these
are real people everybody in there is a
real person you know and so you're
sitting there it's like wow there's John
lewisohn there's Diane Nash and you know
there's mrs. Boynton and I know those
but I've been in that cafe where Jimmie
Lee Jackson was shot and I interviewed
that you know I interviewed the man that
owned that cafe and he told me what
happened and that actually happened
pretty much the way he said it happened
you know so there's a lot of parsing of
truth from fiction but at the end of the
day you have to remember it's a movie I
think from two perspectives that it's an
important film for young people I work
with young people in Harlem and the
contact that I have here on campus and
at other places which student activists
it is a great reminder of how young the
movement
and how students and the portrayal of
John Lewis and sneaking yes stokke was
missing but how young people in the
civil rights movement was and then just
a year or two later people in in the
Black Power movement were students 18 19
21 21 years 22 years old Diane Nash John
Lewis the folks were really on the
forefront and the folks from with even
in the structure of the civil rights
movement pushed to people who were
slightly older remember dr. King was
quite young he died at 38 39 years old
pushed them more not to back down even
within the context of the nonviolent
revolution this is an important image to
see when our young people through
television and through netflix and
through hulu are seeing all kinds of
negative images the violent images the
Fast and the Furious 7 8 9 22 whatever
number we're up to can see some fast and
furious protests and some strong some
strength that's portrayed in terms of
taking on the really bad guys of the
universe when you're talking about the
organization of the united states
government and the FBI as someone who
was a young member of the Black Panther
Party I like the bravery in the honesty
with which the FBI's counterintelligence
program was portrayed which did so much
to attack the civil rights movement in
the black liberation movement anti-war
movement the student movement here at
Columbia University arm speaking from
the other side as a is a filmmaker who
does narrative films understand dramatic
license when you have to take a great
movement that that and condense it into
a great moment in the movement and
condense it in something that's two
hours of film allows in 15 minutes of
film that you will take dramatic license
but from folks who worked in film and I
did this film had a galvanizing effect
in terms of
those of us who were working with
studios and who are working you know
slightly inside and outside of the
Hollywood System in the way that it was
overlooked at the Oscars and I was at a
dinner in February are called the icon
man dinner and two black women organized
the dinner that celebrated black men who
had been nominated or had won Oscars in
the history of the of the of the Academy
and my son's joked at when I accepted
the invitation to to go out there to say
well dad you and the other four guys
should have a great time but it was
actually quite full and David or you a
law was they who played dr. King and
Bradford young the young cinematographer
who shot the movie who photographed the
movie and it was a great celebration in
terms of acknowledging that but the work
that has to be done the Academy had a
chance to make history and nominating
Eva Dubonnet as the first
african-american female to be nominated
for an Oscar it failed to do that and in
so many categories that failed to
acknowledge great filmmaking great work
for an important subject in important
American film and that had the effect of
making black filmmakers kind of come
together in a way to say we will
continue to tell these stories and we
will continue to understand that they
are valid when they move people they're
valid when a film like this can continue
to have life at columbia university but
also it's being shown at middle schools
and primary schools and high schools and
churches and community sentence and that
creates a kind of digital revolution
that we should all be part of Thank You
Susan did you want to I haven't ended up
a follow but it can wait a while yeah
please go ahead I was going to ask pat
williams to to weigh in I again I'm not
I'm hardly a filmmaker but I am really
really intrigued by the fact that this
movie struck me so intimately it was
such an intimate film and part of it is
just having lived through this I was
quite young but not that young I mean I
was a very you know just 12 or 13 at the
time this was
happening so I was very aware and it was
very formative and you know there are a
couple of things that struck me one is
that this is a film that for which there
are transcripts I mean a lot of them are
redacted but actually the FBI does have
transcripts of many of the intimate
moments of this I mean private France
great lament what happens in private yes
but I mean but but but but even what
happens in public my point is that even
what happened in public my understanding
was compromised to some degree in the
making of this film because of the
proprietary fight among the King
children and that really broke my heart
to think about the fact that this
actually is now taking place in a world
where I think all of our civil rights
struggles are taking place against a
backdrop that is so denominated by
proprietary battles over everything so
the intimacy of this was to some degree
disrupted by the fact that I you know at
the age of 12 13 it almost memorized
every word that King said and it was
disconcerting to have well written but
clearly not the kind of singing rhetoric
that were his precise words they were
very very carefully chosen words and
this was written so it was a
representation with some sense of
fiduciary duty and that's what really
intrigues me about the it is not a
documentary but a film has of this that
stature has some sort of fiduciary
responsibility was standing between that
and it's rendering was again a kind of
propriety proprietary world that I think
has become the new edge of politics
because it is proprietary not just about
owning particular words it is you know I
can thinking what would happen what will
happen in today's world if there is a
need for this kind and there certainly
is a social movement that we need in all
kinds of things but could we have this
kind of march on pettus bridge in
today's world and it seems to me that
there are a lot of things militating
against that a lot of that has to do
with technology proprietary interests in
technology
you know battles on the legal field
about whether or not you can who and
what you can film who owes what and who
owns what and and then laws about
security and terrorism because one
wonders what a young movement like this
would meet in today's world where
everything is surveyed it isn't simply a
matter of you know putting a tap on a
wire and every bit of what we do is
surveyed and that surveillance system is
something that I don't see college
students there's no snick movement
people don't seem to feel personally
implicated by the political dimensions
of the fact that every single part of
your lives is being recorded on your
instruments or on your computer or by on
street corner cameras and it seems to me
that you know the apathy in the face of
that is something that you know I would
hope that people would take away from
this movie you know we're not going to
have another civil rights movement when
we needed unless we really begin to
oversee and regulate who can draw from
the palette of representations that are
digitally recorded on every single one
of us and who can assemble who we are in
ways that may or may not be faithful to
the human beings the complexity of the
human beings we are yeah just very
quickly other things really ironic to
you talked about in terms of the
surveillance and almost kind of how we
gladly gave that all back in the face of
911 because the government said that you
know people fought against
counterintelligence pro the Freedom of
Information Act but you look at the
image of the police and you look at the
images of police today the
militarization of police and in the way
they show up in poor communities and the
way they show up in the shootings that's
going on you look at that and you go not
that much has changed except the weapons
are better and the body armor is better
but that same kind of marvelous quaint
compared to police officers in Ferguson
right here the horses and billy clubs
are nothing to add to Bearcat yeah
armored vehicles that's right you know I
think each generation has to invent its
movement for itself I don't think this
generator imeem you know we sort of
solve at the big with a cube
the beginnings of a movement that didn't
really have a direction and a strategy
or tactics then oddly enough out of the
same generation we're seeing now what I
would think of as a second civil rights
movement are surrounding the use of cell
phones to capture police misconduct and
we've now got just in the last week
three policemen who are suddenly you
know their stories are unraveling as a
result of individuals with cell phones
who are you know engaged in
revolutionary the revolutionary act of
recording a cop yeah and unraveling the
stories that the police try to tell so I
think it's you know I always you know
there's a part of me that's you know
nostalgic for you know like the good old
days when we were marching but you know
the Rev we that that movement
accomplished what it could accomplish
and now we're in a new world at a new
age and you know your generation is
going to have to figure out what
revolution you're going to create with
the instruments at hand you know this is
why I think net neutrality was such a
huge victory you know that we still have
some control even though they're
watching us all the time yeah they can't
watch all of us what do they think I
wanted to I actually wouldn't wanted to
ask you CML so your your thoughts I just
wanted to weigh in on a small bit which
is that you know most of my life as a
lawyer has been as a law reform lawyer
mainly on LGBT and HIV related issues
and one of the things that struck me
watching dr. King and the group
strategize and I saw this more the
second time watching the film that I did
the first time was how profoundly
contemporary the political strategy was
right the sense of how to mix the public
attention to the issue with the
on-the-ground organizing and the lawyers
sort of doing what they could to secure
the right to march and the the tensions
in the social movement right that were
there then that are that are present in
any social movement right but that run
through every social movement and one of
the challenges and I think I see this
with in talking with students often as
the expectation that you know there is a
social movement that has a vision and
and it's not successful unless it sort
of achieves that vision
lock step and it's never been that way
I'm part of what you see is even with
the diversity of views and the diversity
of strategies there is this way that a
shared end goal comment from many
different perspectives can be moved
forward there are ways to get there and
I think that for me as part of what is
inspiring and reinvigorating one I think
about steps that we are all or each of
us is trying in different ways to take
today Sam do you want to weigh in with
your some of your thoughts about the
film as well actually I think for
instance you do quickly yeah I just want
to briefly comment on some of the things
that Pat and you mentioned which I think
one of the things that struck me
politically of the film precisely had to
do with I mean many people have pointed
out the continuities the police
brutality that kind of thing but some of
the things that struck me are the
discontinuities one of which is that
although the film attempts to create a
private sphere for Martin Luther King
and include women to some extent in that
narrative we're still talking about a
movement that had a clear leader a model
of organization that I think has become
impossible so I think one of the
questions that the film asks for me is
that is precisely has to do with how
much things have changed in terms of how
we conceive of social movements for
instance we have a huge social movement
in this country around immigration
rights does anybody know who the leader
is there is no leader you know there's a
multiplicity of actions in various
fronts with various tactics and various
relationships to each other using media
which is something that the film and the
moment about the moment and the film
capture and anticipate that that would
be a very important aspect of
mobilization but with the contradictions
that you have been mentioned or the
paradoxes of this new digital moment so
in that regard I think one question to
be explored it's actually not only the
continuities that are the questions that
the film raises that we might recognize
as still problems to this day but also
the discontinuity because that does
raise the questions of strategies
and modes of mobilization yeah I
particularly like that point as well and
one of my reactions to the film this is
might as well my second time seeing it
and I'm also having a different reaction
to it as well I do have first of all I
like the film I'm not a filmmaker so you
want me to take issue with it I like to
lose executed I thought the acting was
particularly good I'm again I'm not even
a film critic so as well but i also have
and this goes back some of the gym said
earlier i do have some questions about
the differences or what are the elisions
or the very fine lines between dramatic
license and even though i am a historian
I will allow dramatic lights inside I'm
not you know i don't kind of fetishize
the archive and every my new detail has
to be you know in place and absolutely
quote unquote correct but at the same
time then i believe that there should be
literary license but there are some
things that give me pause so far as june
pointed out what does it mean not to
have a Stokely Carmichael there in just
a Malcolm X to represent a different way
of thinking about a civil rights
movement have we inadvertently
recapitulated or reiterated you know
very popular liberal narrative which is
that Martin Luther King led the civil
rights movement and we all lived happily
ever after and that's clearly not the
case 50 years later we're voting rights
are you know in high jeopardy as we
began thinking about this so I this is
there is a moment where Stokely
Carmichael is telling Martin King why
don't you just say the words black power
it's not that difficult and and and June
will tell you because it's in the the
documentary I think it might be the one
that you produced in the that one of the
episodes that you worked on june so
there is this moment where King is not
the only game in town and he's not the
challenging figure that we would like to
believe he is challenging but there are
others who are pushing in different
directions there's also a way in which i
think in this film we are thinking of
King as tying voting rights to economic
rights in
I don't think he white not just yet I
think the line that what good is
integrated lunch counters that you can't
buy a burger I think it's something that
he actually said in early is 66 and i
want to say was 67 when he's moving
towards the poor people's March and its
really endears work where the literary
license i think is acceptable to a point
it's really there when LBJ is sick of
its really in 67 like I don't think
Martin had really done the public ratite
sup Vietnam in 65 in the film we have
them saying or you can send troops to
Vietnam but not i'm not sure usually
saying that publicly where is in 60 70 s
that moral crisis and says i can no
longer be just about civil rights just
about voting rights and think that's
fine without critiquing american
imperialism so there is a bit kind of
there's a bit of crushing of a very
complex four years into one year there i
mean those are my immediate reaction
yeah yeah and that great speech of
course in Riverside a year before he was
killed on Riverside show poverty poverty
racism and war and really connects those
things but there's something else that I
agree with that that point that you made
but the other thing I think that it did
do at and again knowing what film does
for filmmakers and for aspiring
filmmakers for young people it's the
emotional truth it's the fact that a few
of us watched it and this is my second
time seeing the film and fought back
tears and that I think will inspire two
things for for people to be to
understand that activism can be an
occupation and a hat vocation that it's
cool to be active it's cool to question
and critiqued and to whatever Frances as
you said the movement takes you know the
new models and that they'll go back and
investigate and watch eyes on the prize
and read the books ago it didn't really
happen like that it happened this way
and that that's great anything I think
that opens the door and spurns that
interest in that way is exciting to me
as a filmmaker innocent as an educator
in the biggest aha moment for me was
just tearing down that sort of stone
image of Martin King in front of the
link
monument saying I have a dream if I have
to see that thing one more time when
done yeah I mean here we have a martin
king who actually is a father he's a
husband he's a womanizer you know and
all those facets of him are represented
and I actually found that really
fascinating i love the way I thought she
handled that really really well whether
or not they were true and you know who
knows who cares it was so at least I had
to think about and we readjusted air
ative that is so often presented of King
especially in February when we have to
or in January around his birthday when
we all have to watch that dag on speech
as if he never made any other speech in
his life Pat can I just evan is it one
of I again I was got carried away by the
emotion as well but I'm also suspicious
of the way the emotion was structured in
terms of how to use that for current
political purposes or what one can do
within the university since that was the
question we were asked or or as a lawyer
maybe that's the question I heard but
which is that it has a kind of emotional
Struth structured around good and evil
and so it's striking that you know if we
are not if we don't have a Martin Luther
King right now we also don't have a J
Edgar Hoover right now and so it's a
much more De strange sense of political
right now we absolutely have the
surveillance but it's it's that
invisible panopticon where we don't know
whose eyes and it is a multiple we do it
ourselves if it's it's a well we do it
to ourselves but it's we it is clearly
being done to us too yeah and any time
you look at I agree or if you actually
read the USA patriot act it is being
done to us if you look at what's
happening in spain spain just passed a
gag laws supposedly which says you can't
have you can't film police with your
cell phones everything that were kind of
worried about here you can't demonstrate
within a certain number of feet of the
city hall and so forth and so quite
extreme one with huge fines associated
with it and the response to it was
really quite a wonderful bit of
performance art of if you it's online i
think it's gone viral a youtube video of
thousands of people individually filming
themselves sent into a central thing and
then they projected it in front of the
hall of the first holographic protest
out in front of the in front of the city
hall and that's wonderful and it's
performative but it also strikes me as
being the kind of difficulty of you know
that we we're going to have holographs
you know as perhaps a form of our
freedom of expression will that have the
same power as blocking a bridge because
you can walk right through a hologram
Bull Connor can ride his horse right all
right over it and I I think its
expressive but it is is it the kind of
intimate human expression that is going
to motivate the politics I think we need
to to push back against the sense that
unless we can form we're all going to be
in danger but it's an unseen danger it's
not an Aimable danger it's it doesn't
have a head or a heart it doesn't have a
jegar Hoover or Martin Luther King and
that's that's a diaphanous kind of new
danger in some ways I think the power of
a film like this especially for people
who are used to learning visually and
used to learning through powerful
emotional stories is to help create the
entree into a reminder about why it is
so important not only to do what one
does on the internet or in the Holograms
but due to do it in person and to engage
in person let me just oppose it time is
flying here so I want to pose a couple
of the questions that we received via
Twitter and then I guess everybody just
was out of respecting the time has about
a minute to respond to either of these
any of these or or anything else you'd
like it's the lightning round that you
told us about you promised a lightning
rod ground lightning round exactly
exactly the buzzers are ready okay so
I'll just consolidate a couple of them
here and when one is how do you think
that conversations like this a tie the
league universities elite institutions
can affect how people think about these
issues in the real world and a second is
in light of events like the killings in
Staten Island and North Charleston how
do you think contemporary Americans can
protest in a meaningful way so these
actually intersect to some degree with
the conversations were already having
but let me
turn it to the lightning round for each
of you to share your thoughts briefly I
mean you guys are going to graduate from
here and go out and be judges and
lawyers and leaders of movements and
you're going to be writing policy papers
and working for congressman or working
in public health and doing things I mean
I think it's very relevant that you
begin to question to what degree are you
living in your ivory tower and to what
degree can you take the lessons of a
Selma and apply it to your life yeah I
do think that the power of the people
the power of marching in protests is
still relevant it's still amazing to see
bodies on the street bodies at
University protesting that Harry
Belafonte talks about the civil rights
issue of today he's been involved from
then till now the issue of mass
incarceration the issue of police
shootings and murders and that's
something that's going to require body
is not just Holograms we're buddies on
the street protesting question
universities about divesting from
corporations of their portfolios from
corporations that are doing businesses
with this growing population I know I'm
over a minute but common and John Legend
when they accept that they Oscar said
something that bears thinking about that
there are more black men in prison today
tonight as we speak then they were in
Chains at the height of slavery that is
something to rally around and fight
around and to find a mass movement that
we all join in and then what we would do
in those rooms is learn about what was
going on in the women's movement in the
immigration movement and they gave
liberation movement and understand that
it was one struggle we almost have too
much information now we spend a lot of
time digesting we had less information
and more acting not to be nostalgic but
to understand that movement is about
action I mean I I do worry that the
social media gives
a false sense of intimacy rather than
the actual intimacy of what that
movement represented and so that I can
project a hologram but still be behind
walls still within my gated community
still never actually have the kind of
encounter of that was so miraculous
about those marches in those days when
blacks and whites really saw each other
for the first time and and I do worry
that you know there may be some of that
that we transmit with with with cameras
but I still think we live in very
separated much more separated worlds of
imagination about each other and the
only way we overcome that is actually by
having our bodies on the line for and
with each other and not from a distance
I think I just want to comment on the
question that Suzanne pose I think it's
very complex how do we let's say in a
space like Columbia which is a space of
enormous privilege the question becomes
how do we mobilize that privilege to
undermine the foundations that produces
it to some extent and I think a
practical question I guess for everyone
and I certainly raise this question
myself being part of the Ivy League is
what what is it that we can do with the
resources the symbolic capital that we
have in order to transform our society
and that I don't think it's an easy
answer I don't think it's a inherently a
question of the same we go to the
streets together or you know these are
complex questions that we face every day
in our in our lives as we become
professionals as we become members of
the elite if we're not already so I
think that that is you know I think a
question for all of us to talk about
because I don't think it has an easy or
simple answer
I'm I I have a bit of a different
perspective of that in terms of what I
what students could do here I think 50
years ago each of the volunteers that we
see in the news the young volunteers
that we've seen the newsreels not all of
them but many of them had parents at
home and said what is this you're
getting involved in this is dangerous
it's silly you're going to be labeled a
communist are you gonna get a good jobs
is why we paid tuition money for you to
go to college etc etc I think that has
not changed I think there is a game in
elite education that that hustle is
still there right there's a hustla it's
going to scare all of us into believing
if we don't you know have the right
major and get the right GPA we're going
to all be just living on the streets you
know there's that rat race and I see it
in my students where they're just you
know really just burning themselves out
at age 19 not a very healthy way to go
about education i would say i think
there are many examples today that
proved that to be a lie there are many
people who were activists coming into
college coming into columbia coming into
barn are coming into harvard princeton a
lot of places Princeton but I jest with
Princeton and have made you know very
fruitful and i don't mean monetarily but
you know they were feeding themselves
but i mean very rewarding careers
fruitful with what they with with what
they did i I'm not sure I agree with
Francis on the point about you know can
we can we leverage elite status to
dismantle the foundations of that system
that is yeah that is the problem of the
age on the other hand there is a way in
which if the Masters tools cannot
dismantle the Masters house you know
maybe you can steal the tools and build
your own house to kind of you know
rephrase the the old line and that you
can take what you learn here and do
something that's not part of the hustle
that's being sold to you they're wasting
like that I don't disagree
that that that is a choice people can
make definitely and students do I'm just
raising the that this is a large
question that some people make that
choice which doesn't totally abolish the
contradictions and the paradoxes of it
but yet can make a contribution to to to
the dialogue and to the process so I
just want to so I'm not saying that
people are not doing it necessarily I'm
just saying that it is a complex
question and it confronts us with a
myriad of choices and people are not all
making the same choices and that even
the choices that we might find to be the
correct choices or the the right choices
politically are still you know begging
more more questions I mean it's not the
end I mean just saying I'm going to be
an activist is not the end of the
questions yes absolutely and I'll just
pick up an echo that one of the things
that I sometimes see is that students
feel that they have to choose between
being an activist or a serious student
or being an athlete or a scholar or an
activist or an advocate and I think part
of what you're hearing from all of us in
different ways is that those are those
also are false dichotomies right one can
and and ought to really engage in that
many different ways of participating and
thinking about these questions and
learning about them right and so on many
questions we are all at the same time
students and teachers and it's important
in some ways to remember that because
then we take some responsibility both
for learning and for sharing what we've
learned and I think that is a piece
that's also invaluable at me for each of
us as we think about where where to go
next and I thought I would just close
our evening by sharing one other point
that President Obama made on pettus
bridge which I think also follows to
some degree on this question which is
that if he said if Selma has taught us
anything it's that our work is never
done the American experiment in
self-government gives work and purpose
to each generation selma teaches us as
well that action requires that we shed
our cynicism
I'm not sure everybody on the panel
would agree with that but I'll just heat
that's what he said quote for when it
comes to the pursuit of justice we can
afford neither complacency nor despair
on behalf of the office of university
life I'd like you to join me in thanking
the panelist and I invite you to
continue the conversation both this
evening and beyond thank you all very
much
you